sometimes when guys talk about you know
when they realized they had respect to
their peers or they felt vindicated they
can remember like a specific guy
saying something to them and they said
oh when he knew i was nice wow i knew i
was nice that's a great is there someone
like that for you yeah
and it's crazy that's crazy that's
one person who who
my rookie year told me something that
stuck with me
i don't even know if you remember this
it was michael red he told me i was
going to be special in this league
keep
keep don't stop
like i just remember those words so
vividly you won't be special in the
league don't stop
keep working this is my rookie year
michael red
i never got the chance to tell him thank
you for that he might he may not even
remember but michael read
told me those words and it stuck with me
to this day really why do you think in
that moment like that was so it
resonated so deeply i don't know at that
time you know he was
he was a veteran you know he was an
established player he was a player like
i've always been a fan of the game of
basketball
70s 80s 90s so i always respect
respected all the older guys i honest i
respected what michael redd did
did in the league
um
and i don't know it was just that moment
where he put me to the side and you know
i felt how genuine he was about it you
know what i mean because even at that
point my rookie year you know you
you you deal with so many
emotions
questioning like damn when i'm when i'm
gonna be good when i'm gonna be able to
be myself i'm gonna be comfortable like
i'm only 19 years old playing with grown
men so for him to put me to the side and
and acknowledge something towards me
that i was feeling iffy about
was all i needed well shout out michael
shut up i love that